I try not to like play a role I just do
what I want to do and keep it real and
if that's not good enough then who can I
be people are respectful and you know so
on and so forth people kind of give you
your time in your space and it's nice
it's nice both ways because I'm quite a
people person I grew up on an estate so
I'm used to being around hundreds of
people my family is massive so it's not
an issue when I'm approached I still do
normal things but the normal things that
I choose to do now as I'm older won't
leave me in the same trouble that I used
to getting when I was younger if it
depends what people class was naughty
right yes I don't know I'm a good guy I
told you I wanted a good guy I think
they see my mom differently because my
mom comes home is they know I got my car
wash for free and I got I've got a
parking space and they told me it was
full I think yeah she I think she
injuries it but it's funny because when
I first told her I want to but she was
like boxing why boxing of all things and
she started to see like the discipline
the dedication and I've matured through
the sport and now she sees like the
benefits and stuff so it's nice to see
her enjoying the fruits of Labor your
dad now yeah
presumably it's quite hard being in camp
because you can't see your little boy
I'm assuming you can't see a little boy
when it whenever you want to is that
tough I think I think my firstborn my
son is going to grow to be like me
hard-working understand the sacrifices
because I think that he's he's like what
they call the heir to the front so I'm
gonna have to like not trim to kind of
be tough wise make critical decisions
because even though he's my son he's my
friend
in years to come when I have more kids
and I'm a bit more settled I think
they'll be like a lot more softer
because they'll have that daddy love but
me and my boy now I think we're on a
mission together and I'm guiding him now
do you know I mean he's only 18 months
yeah
I can see his future I would rather him
start from the top using his brain I had
to start in the middle using my fists
and some people start with their feet
using playing football so if he can
start from the top I'll be happy but if
he wants to fight he has to use this as
well and kind of navigate his way
through life because boxing on the
outside of the Ring is a business do you
ever doubt yourself there'll be a time
when I'll probably get beat and it's up
to me to come back and like that
redemption and get back on my own get
back to my boxing and my basics and try
and redeem myself that's just how it
goes in the sport everyone is like
two-time heavyweight champ of the world
three-time heavyweight champion of the
world because they once lost and bounced
back
look Klitschko fight was amazing but
that must have taken your confidence as
a boxer to a whole new level because you
you're in trouble
yeah found a way you have to win that
fight when it looked like you might lose
it never does my coach trip me up and
say stay down for 10 seconds and you
know it's always focused on winning so
in that situation it's just who you are
and I think mainly when I watch it back
you know what the saying is that like if
I knew what I knew now would have done
things a lot better so I still got the
win what if I knew what I knew now
looking back I think I would have done
it a lot easier with each punch I were
not the confidence out of them you know
I'm coming from and that's the only way
I can beat him I'm still a threat
because the hunger makes you do crazy
things so I'm still like I'm still a
threat but I'm smarter with my decisions
so it's interesting when the samurai is
hungry because we're sure I've got the
hunger but I'm gonna smile I'm not like
hungry to the point I'll do anything
I'll be calculated with some of the
decisions I make now won't be a next one
would it be David Haye or Deontay Wilder
he he says he would love that fight well
we've got David feathers and Beyonce
whadda these guys talk about me all the
time negative always negative but you
know sooner or later I'll be ramming my
jab down there
do you think you could be the greatest
ever no no no the old score the best
school even when it comes like to music
style quite as now we could never do
like I was unfortunately I think I could
be respected amongst the greats but I
think knows guys paved the way like my
son will never do as good as me right
when he says odd that I'm going to Vegas
I said boy when I was your age I said
you could never do it like we did when
we went Vegas ten years ago the old
score the best school because we paved
the way Eva you're the next Mike Tyson
the next Muhammad Ali or you're nobody
you I mean and if you can become like
not even Mike Tyson just the mike order
Muhammad of the Muhammad Ali it's
amazing because the standards are so
high in boxing even mamuh Darlene lost
Tyson lost but we was talking about that
today
Tyson lost but what's interesting is
that all you ever see is Tyson's
knockouts
so I think you know I've gotta get on
the phone to my PR team and make sure
that they've got this under control
because if I forget me with social media
sky all these people nowadays I need
them to kind of focus on yeah he lost
but he'll be back